[Music]
today we're reviewing amd's rx 6600 xt
video card it is a 380 starting price
this is supposed to be at msrp at least
for this model it's the power color
fighter 6600xt this is a 32cu card it is
navi 23 so it is physically smaller as
silicon than the
previous navi 21 dies for say the 6700
xt and so forth and we'll be reviewing
it for value performance thermals and
most of the other stuff you'll need but
we're keeping this one kind of short
because it's a fairly simple product
review
and not for the best reasons before that
this video is brought to you by arctic
and the liquid freezer 2 line of liquid
coolers which tested among the best in
our thermal charts for cpu coolers the
arctic liquid freezer series has had
continual advancement since our original
review with updates in the mounting kit
including an amd offset bracket for
better thermals and a longer warranty
arctic also has its mx-5 thermal
compound available on the market now if
you need some thermal paste for your
regular maintenance learn more at the
links in the description below
first of all if you want the brochure
the spec sheet we already went through
that in the announcement video for the
6600xe we'll link it below you're
welcome to check it out we're not going
to go through all that again the die
size is significantly cut down that
means that amd can put more dyes per
wafer and should have higher yield per
dot standard metrics from fabrication
facilities is that as the die shrinks it
gets easier to get higher yield so there
are fewer failures fewer rejects so
therefore you get not only more units
per wafer but more good units
out of those that you create as a
percentage so that's the upside to
making a smaller die it means that
depending on what amd pulls from its
other skus whether that's ryzen or other
gpus
it can make a lot more 6600xts as gpu
silicon than it can of say a 6800xd but
we'll see how that pans out 380 was a
sticker shock for basically everyone
when it was announced and if you look at
our comments from the announcement video
of the 6600xt that should become
apparent we'll show a few of them we're
going to keep this really simple for all
of you uh because we don't need to waste
everyone's time to get to the conclusion
for this today so
in the news video with the 6600xt
having only the information of amd's at
the time first party information where
they said we expect to be about 15
better than a 30 60 and we're also going
to be 15 more expensive in msrp so it's
330 versus 380
with a 360 ti 20 bucks above that with
that information alone in the news video
we said
if they're 15 better and they're 15 more
expensive that's a one-to-one scale in
terms of value so our conclusion of the
66 xt will probably be the same as our
conclusion for the 30 60 and probably
very similar to our conclusion for the
30-60 ti at best our conclusion for both
of those was well we'll recap it for you
the price to performance increase is
simply not exciting enough to in any
other generation make a strong
recommendation for this card it's fine
it does well overall but it's not
exciting and in this market that's all
you need to sell all you need is it's
fine in some of these games we're seeing
a one percent dollar increase for a one
percent performance increase which is
not progress it's stagnation and so
that's why we're met on it thanks steve
in other words
at best the conclusion was meh
you'll buy it if you need one because at
this point uh nvidia knew people would
buy anything and the 6600xt as you'll
see in benchmarks today is not bad in
the sense of being objectively bad it's
not like the product is exploding no
one's made anything like that before
by the way that's from our gigabyte
power supply research piece check it out
on the channel and you can still use
code send help for ten percent off on
store.gamersnexus.net
if you'd like to support that type and
this type of testing where you get mod
mats mouse mats and other items
everything on the store for 10 off of
that code right now so anyway
the the product isn't necessarily bad
but the value is suspect and
the market means that the value being
suspect is somewhat irrelevant because
all of them will sell and the companies
know that so if our conclusion was
ranging from meh to
stagnation
with the 30 60 series the ti and the ti
then it is the same for this because
we're seeing still about a one percent
price to one percent performance uh
linear bump
on the scale for the card and
one percent for one percent especially
if you start looking at something like a
5600 xt which is far more value oriented
at 100 cheaper than this
that is not
progress that's not advancement that's
stagnation because comparing to a card
from two years ago where you're looking
at a one-to-one uplift price to
performance
with new architecture it's not moving it
has stayed the same but the price has
increased and the performance gets
dragged up marginally with that to make
it feel like it's an advancement now
we're going to get into the benchmarks
at this point one final thing before we
get into it to to really make sure
everyone understands how we approach
reviews for products there are a lot of
ways to potentially justify the price
increase here
we know
that the memory prices have gone up we
know that materials prices have gone up
that logistics are a nightmare right now
doesn't change the fact that when the
other cards that are on the market do
hit the market and yes we know they are
difficult to get but people are able to
buy them it's just a matter of who it is
and how many but when they hit the
market so when there's a 6700x restock
or maybe more appropriately when there's
a 30 60 or a 360 ti restock it will be
pretty close to the original msrp
despite all these issues and that's
really what matters here it's what else
can you get or if you're looking at an
upgrade what sort of the price to
performance versus your existing card
can you strain it along a little bit
longer and make your 10 or 9 or rx 500
series live for maybe another six months
to a year to see what happens at that
point in the market and of course if you
can because you're relatively happy with
your performance your system it's not
slowing you down in a big way then
probably keep doing that stick with what
you have because it's just better for
you it's less waste and it's less wasted
money but the point is that we're
getting to we have one main approach
when we do reviews and news and our
approach is entirely consumer focused i
don't care what the excuses are for amd
or nvidia or intel for why their prices
are what they are it doesn't matter to
us uh strictly if the memory prices
capacitor prices whatever has gone up
now obviously we consider that and we
consider the company's viewpoint but
ultimately if
in spite of all these considerations the
product is still bad value for the
consumer that's what we're gonna say
because that's what we care about
doesn't matter to me if a company worth
like say intel hundreds of billions of
dollars has an excuse for why its
product is priced the way it is because
if it's still bad value it's bad value
and that hurts the consumer from your
perspective from a buyer's perspective a
lot more than hurts the company's
perspective for me to say that so
although there may be reasonable excuses
for 380 the floor for this product which
will inevitably be sold for far higher
by partners before even scalpers because
they're going to have partner models
that are more expensive although it's
maybe a reasonable excuse
that doesn't change the fact
that the value is kind of brutal where
it is right now compared to previous
generations and the fact that previously
launched cards in this generation have a
better in most instances value position
than this one does
even in spite of materials costs because
you still get them towards msrp if you
happen to snipe one when it restocks and
that largely depends on your region okay
enough of that let's get into the
benchmarks and talk through the card how
it performs if it's worth it you
probably know the answer at this point
uh and just as a reminder it's not
objectively bad it's just we're trying
to watch out for you in terms of the
value of all of these products right now
that's nvidia too we'll start off with
some quick card level performance
looking at gpu thermals on the power
color fighter under a sustained gaming
workload and with auto controls the card
holds a v bios temperature target of
about 73 degrees celsius this has the
hot spot at 87 to 89 degrees celsius so
the edge temperature is completely fine
at 73 it's in a good spot while the hot
spot temperature is technically fine
it's okay we'd like to see the hot spot
to edge delta closer to a gap of just 10
degrees between them rather than upwards
of 16 degrees apart this to us indicates
a mounting pressure and consistency if
people cared enough about individual
partner model reviews these days we
would do the pressure testing and
explore it we could prove all of this
but the time investment balloons and
we've done that recently and
unfortunately the interest is sadly not
supported by the current supply of cards
so suffice to say this should be about
six degrees better on the delta to align
with what we typically see on good
designs the fan ramp is all kinds of out
of whack on the power color fighter this
isn't new for power color the company
has a lot of problems with fan
hysteresis and has had problems with
ramp in the past so it's no surprise to
see it again here at the outset of the
load the card hard ramps to 1900 rpm
while the gpu temperature is still in
the 50s it's going full freak out panic
mode over at this point not much it then
realizes that it's gone too far and
drops to 1430 rpm despite the fact that
the temperature is only increasing at
this point and the load is only ramping
it's not dying down then the card or the
v bios realizes that oops the fan still
needs to be doing stuff and so it ramps
again to 1800 rpm this kind of erratic
behavior creates audible noticeable
change in pitch and tone coming from the
computer and so the user will hear it
power color needs to revamp its fan
curve and view bios to help smooth this
out it needs to be a bit more lag at the
kickoff and then it needs to ramp more
gradually overclocking the rx 6600 xt
wasn't too bad we've gotten more
familiar with the process as amd's gpus
have continued to roll out this chart
shows our raw test notes as we worked
through finding stable settings with a
port royal score used to help validate
the oc with all gpus it's important to
validate the oc settings with scores
after each change
thanks to silent error correction it's
easy to get a higher number on an oc
that actually hurts the real world
performance we ended up settling at 2700
to 2800 for the core clock in amd
software and 200 megahertz offset of the
memory and these actually increased the
memory offset allowance so now there's
room to try and find good memory bins
even beyond this we tried undervolting
all the way down to 1100 millivolts and
although it didn't crash the frequency
was regressing each time we stepped
below 1130 millivolts with higher
settings 11 30 was the best that we got
with a maximum score increase on a
stable oc in all of the games of 7.1 at
least by port royal score that's not bad
it's not exciting but at least it's not
a total waste of time like some of the
two percent uplifts often are shot of
the tomb raider at 1080p has the rx 6600
xt fighter at 135 fps average with lows
at 115 and 109. we'll quickly run
through some stats here the 6600 xtoc
and volt improved results by 2.7 percent
to 139 fps average so it is kind of a
waste of time in this one the rtx 3060
non-ti ran at 123 fps average allowing
the 6600xt lead of 10.3 percent in
exchange for 15 percent more money we
said the rtx 3060 was unexciting for
being about 10 percent more money for
about 11 more performance than the rtx
2060 ko at launch in other words it was
complete and utter stagnation that's
true here too the 6600 xt is improving
over its direct competition
slower than its price is increasing as
for the others the 3060 ti outdoes the
6600 xt by 19 for 5 more msrp versus
older cards upgrading from a 1066
gigabyte would give you over two times
more performance on the 6600 xt as with
the rx 580 to 6600 xt upgrade the 66xt
isn't bad it's just not good value at
1440p the 66xt is still a capable
performer it's running about 92 fps
average stock or 95fps overclocked that
has it near the 5700xt you could play
games at 1440p on this device as
expected despite the heavier marketing
focus on 1080p high refresh the rtx 2060
ko would have been better value at 74
fps average for 300 when it launched and
lower later but it's hard to find those
cards now versus the 3060 the 66xt
offers nine percent more performance for
15 more money the lead slips as
resolution increases thanks to nvidia's
advantages at higher resolution the 360
ti now holds a lead of 22
instead of 19
the 66 xt leads the rx 580 and the gtx
1060 by upwards of 120
at 4k the rx 6600xt held about 49 fps
average with the oc offering five
percent more performance it's actually
not bad you could play 4k in some games
on this card if the graphic settings
were tuned down a little bit the 3060 ti
ends up 33 ahead for now 5 more msrp for
whatever that's worth and the 30 60 ends
up roughly time the 6600 xt nvidia
remains somewhat competitive at the
higher resolutions while amd remains
somewhat competitive at the lower
resolutions in three kingdoms at 1080p
the 6600xt ran at 72fps average with our
more abusive graphic settings that has
about equal with the 3060 and allows the
360 ti a lead of 35 percent so far the
6600 xt is making the 360 ti look like
good value despite the fact that the 360
ti was ultimately meh value at launch
it's a technical term when compared to
other generations previously versus
those previous generations the 6600xt
outdoors the 5600 xt by about 19
while the price crept up by about 36
generationally and these previous gen
was better value again an rx 580 or a
gtx 900 series or a 10 series card would
get more meaningful uplift from this
jaunt
but that doesn't change the value
proposition at 1440p the rx 6600xt drops
to 44 fps average that's expected in
this title since we run the graphics at
ultra you'd still be able to support
60fps 1440 if dropping settings for this
one but we test for relative scaling
more than anything the 6600xt maintains
better low proportions here than the
nvidia cards are doing which is behavior
we've seen regularly from this series of
games the 6600xc is 19 ahead of the 5600
xd the 3060 is about equal to the 6600
xt but with worse lows and the 6600 xtoc
improved by six percent landing on par
with the 5700 xt at 4k the 6600 xt is
unplayable but still useful for scaling
data the 3060 now technically pulls
ahead in average although not
meaningfully and the 3060 ti gaps up
overall though it's a wash between all
of these so we'll move on red dead
redemption 2 at 1080p has the 6600 xt at
105 fps average with good lows it leads
the 30 60 by 16 percent the 2060 by 34
and the rx 580 by 90
it also leads the 10 and 900 series by
what is known to scientists as a lot of
percent the 360 ti leads it by 12 here
not as impressive as in some other
titles although it's still technically
ahead at 1440p the 6600xd ended up at 77
fps to 81 depending on the clocks that
has it about 10 ahead of the 30 60. so
we're not really seeing and these 15
claims thus far and uh it also has the
30 60 ti about 21 percent ahead here
time to look at one of those high
refresh titles that amd was talking
about in rainbow six siege at 1080p the
rx 6600 xt ran at 321 fps average with
the oc improving 4.3 percent the 3060 ti
maintains a lead of just 12 percent here
with the 3060 being led by the 6600 xt
by 15
there's that amd marketing number
finally it's in a more esports-focused
title that we see amd's claims of 15
being realized this at least aligns with
the focus though of 1080p high refresh
esports style titles at 1440p the rx
6600 xt remains capable and runs at 188
fps average up to 200 with the overclock
the 360 ti pulls ahead now with a 31
lead instead of the previous 12 lead and
the 36 d approaches parity now allowing
the 6600 xt a 3.9 percent lead at 4k the
6600 xt is still in playable territory
we've dropped below the truly high
refresh range but at 82 fps average it's
still doing well for this class of cart
unfortunately the rtx 2060 ko is right
behind it unnoticeably behind at 79 fps
average despite the 27 higher price on
the 6600 xt we've established a pattern
at this point so it's time to get
through this faster you can pause if you
care in the division 2 at 1080p the rx
6600 xt holds at about 150 fps average
stock or 7 percent higher with the oc
this 6600 xt ends up just behind the
5700 xt and just ahead of the 3060
leading the ladder by 7.7
the 3060 ti flanks the 6600 xt with a 27
lead at 1440p the 6600xt ran at 96 fps
average so again it's a capable 1440p
performer and it remains predictably
flanked by the nvidia 360 class cards in
cyberpunk 2077 at 1080p with our test
environment the 6600xt manages about 77
fps average stock or 85 overclocked
that's actually a big gain of 10 far
better than we saw anywhere else it's
not bad actually for an oc and would be
worth it the 3060 ends up just ahead of
the 6600 xt but they're basically tied
with the 360 ti ahead of the stock 66xt
by about 32 percent we'll next look at
some games with ray tracing features
enabled we'll keep this section very
short uh we'll likely add more in our
gpu methods overhaul for next generation
but right now we're just going to look
at the two opposites which would be tomb
raider and then minecraft tomb raider
starts us off this one is more
rasterization heavy than rt heavy it
just has shadows for rte so andy will do
better here than it will do in rt heavy
titles we get emails about this
particular thing every time so to be
extremely clear
this is a different test than the
earlier tomb raider test rt is on for
this one but it was off before and
that's why the numbers are different
it's the the whole the point of it the
6600 xt managed 68 fps average here
allowing the 30 60 a lead of 12
that's flipped from before the 360 ti is
now 43 percent ahead which is a major
lead versus the 66 xt and this is in a
title where by rt standards andy is in a
far better position nvidia is still the
leader for rt performance overall at
1440p the 6600xt ran at 46 fps average
allowing nvidia a 12 lead on the 36d or
44 on the 360 ti the 2060 is also
embarrassingly close to the 6600 xt
that's embarrassingly for amd's here not
nvidia's in minecraft with full ray
tracing the 6600xt ends up at 27 fps
average at 1080p with no
dlss or fsr equivalent in this game and
this allows the 360 ti a significant
lead even with dlss off and these
struggles here for power consumption the
rx 6600 xt ended up pulling about 155
watts stock or 188 when overclocked with
the 20 power offset allowed by this card
that has it below the rtx 3060 and
therefore more efficient in performance
except ray tracing when both are stock
and also below the 360 ti with a
reduction of 23 power consumption
although the performance is also lower
okay some quick recaps from the
benchmarks you should have just watched
them they're pretty short this time
we kept it all short for a reason we
know what the interest level is right
now for gpus and we know that people are
basically going to buy it regardless of
what reviewers say but we put enough out
there for you to make a conclusion how
it performs hopefully that helps you in
an objective sense however we are
limiting the amount of extra work we're
doing on this one because it just
frankly it's
people just don't care enough so that's
the way it is right now but hopefully
we'll get back to pressure testing uh
noise testing all that stuff in the
future so for now value uh
to put this in perspective the rtx 2060
achieves in one of these games 80
percent of the performance at 79 of the
price ideally we would want to see
a
break of rank there so it's not
one-to-one increase in price and
performance you want to see uh the the
price increase at a shallower curve as
the performance increases because that
illustrates improvement rather than
stagnation because you could have gotten
that two years ago
at the same curve that it's at now
so that's the main problem we had with
it versus previous generations again the
66 xt in some instances without doing
the 5600 xd depending on the game by
saying around 20 20 19 one of the games
we looked at while price crapped up 36
percent msrp to msrp uh again comparing
total war for that one so that's not
great
you don't
generationally
uh
it really shouldn't be going that
direction
some of the argument again can be
stemmed by materials costs and logistics
but we review products based on whether
they're worth it for the consumer
and in this instance the only reason
it's it's really worth it is the same
reason the 36 and the 360 ti are worth
it which is
it's cheap ish compared to the 3080 and
the 6800
uh what else are you gonna buy so
our recommendation is this it's we take
a very
i think down to earth approach to it
which is that
if you have a system you're happy with
today
then and you can't explicitly pinpoint
why you might want to upgrade
if you're only considering upgrading
because new stuff is coming out as we
always say probably stick with what you
have
if you can explicitly pinpoint why you'd
want to upgrade so you're unhappy with
it you
use your computer for work and it's
slowing you down and therefore cost you
money or you use it for fun and it's no
longer fun because it's not fast enough
and it is costing you time it's costing
you the enjoyment of your time that you
would like to spend on something uh as a
hobby gaming then it is time to upgrade
uh but
what you upgrade to
in this market you can take a little bit
of time and think about it because
it's just everything sells out very
quickly so whether you're quick on the
draw or not the only time that matters
is the instant it stocks on the site and
if you missed that instant then it seems
like the restocking intervals are
difficult to predict unless you're a bot
so at that point might as well take some
time to think about it maybe i should
look at ebay or
whatever
and look at alternative options
ultimately you're getting taken for a
ride if you buy this at 380
or more this is a joke uh it is
insulting that nvidia and amd are
selling things for this much because and
before anyone tries to buy into this
supply
increase and cost angle which is
somewhat true
if you look at
the earnings reports of these public
companies their margins have gone up how
does that happen well it's because
they're making more money per product so
again our perspective is consumer
focused we don't care about whatever
the companies want to say to
justify their price because ultimately
when i look at the public earnings
reports i see they're making insane
money amd is up 100 year over year their
margin is up nvidia's margin is up that
doesn't happen by accident it's not bad
for them to make more money and our view
of it is if you can avoid
buying this card today then avoid it if
you can keep using what you have keep
using it enjoy it do what you can to
make it last longer that's great for the
environment anyway and it's great for
your wallet so it works whether or not
you care about one or the other but so
the card the 6600xt it's fine uh it's
not bad
and the same is true with the 3060 and
the ti is just that we're not excited
about it we have lost all enthusiasm for
this class of cards it's
we really want to see low end stuff we
understand that the company's argument
of course asp is high average selling
price is high people buy everything why
would it make cheaper stuff when we can
satisfy shareholders by maintaining high
asp saying look at all this growth year
over year at our asp it's so much higher
per unit that we sell
but
it's just we can't get excited about it
because we've seen the market for over a
decade at this point and this isn't the
market that i like to see and that makes
it hard for me to
really endorse any of these products in
any way other than to say if you need it
we don't absolutely hate it uh and the
fighter card
at f's rp it seems to do okay it's got
some problems with the fan curve
otherwise it's all right
that's the best i can say about it is
that it's all right uh but the value is
not where we want it to be that's it for
this one thanks for watching as always
subscribe for more you go to
store.camerasex.net
to help us out directly if you'd like to
buy a mouse mat modmat or other item on
the store and you can use code send help
for the next few days for 10 off that
was to help support our gigabyte power
supply testing efforts which you can see
on the channel otherwise go to
patreon.comgamersnexus for behind the
scenes videos we'll see you all next
time